all right uh so thank you for
inviting me to speak today we're all in
this era of speaking
into webcams and uh
it uh it's always better to be able to
see the people you're talking to
but this is the best we got these days
so
uh regardless of anything else uh the
title of my talk is appropriate it is
time
for time and in this acronym
time t-i-m-e stands for the tumor
immune micro-environment so when it
comes to cancer
immunology is what it's all about today
and it's what we're going to talk about
first a few disclosures i have been
funded by a variety of
uh industrial collaborators including
bristol myers
um leica and appirio
at leica which is a
startup company trying to do slide free
histology pfizer and agenda
none of these has actually paid me only
funding
for the research projects with the
exception of i am getting an honorarium
for this presentation today
so that's my full disclosure my
objectives today
are and i've tried to keep them
straight forward for you all and not get
too complicated but
uh the tumor immune microenvironment
is complex and so this will just be sort
of an introduction into
what we know about the tumor immune
micro environment today
and what we're studying for the future
i have a focus which has been the focus
of my laboratory
on experimental pathology and developing
next generation mouse models of human
cancers
and maybe a few of the new technologies
that i see in in very common use
in research today but very rapidly
i think translating into clinical
diagnostics and then the focus
for me scientifically is to
really attack some of the biggest
problems i study breast cancer so you're
going to hear mostly about breast cancer
today
and the three biggest problems at least
in my opinion
when it comes to breast cancer are
treatment of metastatic disease
reducing the overtreatment of indolent
or
non-lethal disease and that's
the result of sort of this failed
promise of early diagnosis where
we all believed that mammograms were
going to dramatically reduce the
impact of um
of breast cancer the way pap smears
dramatically
decreased the impact of cervical cancer
but it really has not lived up to that
promise
finally i hope that some of you will
take this as a conceptual framework
for how to build teams and really do
team science to tackle questions
that are beyond the scope of of the old
way of doing research where
a single lab and maybe a single gene or
a single gene pathway
was being unraveled in a lot of detail
there's a lot of value to that
and certainly that has been important to
the way we think about
cancer um but taking a bigger picture
approach
is now necessary especially as we start
to talk about cancer immunology
so a lot of this starts from
this important paper i mean obviously
even before this paper there was
a lot of research in the area of tumor
immunology but this one
really got the ball rolling again where
jerome gallon was able to show
that just taking small biopsies
of colon cancers you could predict the
outcome of patients
based on the infiltration of t cells so
those are the cd3 cells and whether
those were
outside or infiltrating into the tumor
and in this case also looking at cd5
45 ro as a second marker and using those
two
in ratios could separate even
the if you look at panel c at the bottom
even the early stage disease you could
find
the ones that were going to behave very
badly
versus the more common um good behavior
lesions
sort of in this very well-separated
kaplan-meier plot
um so that started us thinking and i
just want to
go back a little bit and get everybody
on the same page
of where we are in cancer today so a few
years back
we realized that lung cancers could be
stratified based on egfr mutations this
was a new revolution
these egfr mutations predicted response
to
specific therapies and i've listed
two of them there and this
gave rise to the question um
about if we have better sequencing
technology
and it's become cheaper and cheaper to
sequence the cancer genome or any genome
for that matter maybe we should get
should be looking at that
for sort of all patients and if we look
at
cancer genomes for all patients
we can take a different approach to the
way
traditional diagnostics and therapy
decisions were made so traditionally we
would diagnose a cancer in a certain
organ system
that organ system cancer would go
through a series of clinical trials to
figure out what the best
cancer therapies are and
it was sort of done as an empirical or a
series of empirical experiments
to determine what were the best
therapies but here
the nci established what was called the
match trial
with the idea that you could look for
specific mutations that would predict a
response to a specific therapy
and you could do that regardless of
where that tumor
originated so an egfr mutation in the
lung or an egf
r mutation in any other location
would give you a target for therapy
regardless of
pre-existing known sort of efficacy in
that organ system
so this is a very simplistic kind of
approach
actually as complicated as it is because
it's still one gene at a time
one gene relating to one drug at a time
um
doug hannahan and bob weinberg
published in about 2000 sort of a subway
map of the hallmarks to cancer and if
you think of cancer here and egypt r is
on this list i don't have a mouse to
point at it but there's
other genes on this list some of them
are druggable some of them are not
but if you think about cancer just in
terms of the subway map
from the 2000 era we think
that it makes sense to look at one gene
and one therapy
regardless of whether that cancer arose
in the colon the lung or somewhere else
but even hanahan and weinberg have
recognized and so
uh in about 2011 they published
an update of the hallmarks of cancer and
you can see now they've
added quite a few additional
and very important hallmarks here
so on this list now some of the same
intrinsic cancer cell pathways
such as sustaining proliferation so
proliferation signaling are still there
but some others are now here on this
list that
i think we should make note of so
avoiding immune destruction
so immuno evasion
uh tumor promoting inflammation the
micro environment
is here and all these things
really mean that our our old way of
thinking about cancer was too simplistic
and we need to
be thinking much more about cancer in
its micro
environment so here's a very simplified
cartoon of that just introducing you to
some of the cast of characters and you
all know this
uh pretty well already but
it it sort of illustrates that with just
an oversimplified view of two different
um active t cells as well as t
regulatory cells dendritic or antigen
presenting cells macrophages the myeloid
derived suppressor cells and the nk
cells
again i could go on but that introduces
this panel now of seven different
new cells that we need to be looking for
and trying to interrogate
their interactions with tumors
so the other big boost to tumor
immunology has been the great success
of a new class of drugs to
specifically target the immune
checkpoint
pd-1pdl1 and this is just a cartoon
of that illustrating the
immunotherapy for cancer and how these
drugs work it's
oversimplified of course but some cancer
cells and
we found this first in lung cancer cells
have figured out how to fool the immune
system by expressing
uh this pdl1 antibody
program cell death ligand one which
interacts with the t
cell and tells the t cell hey if you're
recognizing me
you're recognizing self and you need to
just calm down and get out of here and
if you block that interaction and we've
got
now drugs from four different companies
which are antibodies either against
pd1 or pdl1 they all perform about the
same
they block this interaction so the
cancer cells no longer
able to tell the t cell that there's
nothing to see here and the t
cells then will attack the cancer again
and this can have great effect so many
of you know
a few years ago jimmy carter had
melanoma metastatic to his brain
and was treated with a anti-pd-1 pdl1
therapy
and has had a durable response he's now
cancer free and he remains
such and has done very well
so if you look at the pd1 pdl1
checkpoint inhibitors
there's really still if you took all
comers of patients with metastatic
disease
only about 2.2 percent complete response
partial responses may be closer to 20
and so this has resulted in a big deal
for us
in the clinic um trying to segregate
patients
based on their tumor characteristics and
expression of pbl1 on tumor cells or
on non-tumor cells in proximity and then
as a surrogate for tumors that have
a high neoantigen
presentation possibility we look for
total mutational burden so tumors that
have a higher
total mutational burden make more
tumor antigens or neo antigens that
don't look like self and those
patients are also better candidates for
this pd-1 pdl1
checkpoint so in
in pathology we spend a lot of time
trying to figure out
how to score the immunohistochemistry
and i won't go into all the details
this is just one of multiple guides this
is for head and neck squamous cell
carcinoma
put out by deco who makes one of the two
main antibodies
used for this purpose and you can see
that
it takes a 69-page document to
educate a pathologist how to interpret
the ihc for pdl1 so this
i think is still a work in progress but
i wanted to ask a more specific question
about
how might we improve
therapy for pd-1 pdl-1 therapy and so
here
i um like to go back to experimental
pathology
and it's hard to do these studies in
cell culture you really need a mouse
and you need a mouse which has an intact
immune system so
many of the models that we use are human
xenographs and mice
or more recently the so-called pdx mice
which are patient-derived
xenographs all of these are in mice with
very deplete immune
deficient um contacts and so
my interest has been for the last 20
years to try and improve our mouse
models
that um that have intact immune systems
and
you know ralph waldo and emerson knew
about this back in the 1800s
and said his often misquoted
witticism about building a better
mousetrap it was actually
building a better mouse and the world
will be a path to his door and that's
certainly been the case for me my lab
built
a better mouse we built this mouse
in 2005 or published in 2005 where we
looked at two very closely related cell
lines that we derived from
transgenic mice the so-called met 1 and
db
7 cells and these
are now transplantable so you can use
them with all the convenience of
xenografts
but they're transplantable into immune
intact mice because they're syn genetic
with those immune intact
mice many of our mouse lines that we use
are
are our congenital mouse lines and so
they
are like um identical twins throughout
the entire
colony and therefore they will
not recognize as non-self tumors which
were derived from
syngenetic animals so this
model system um has been used
by lots of investigators and i just
recently looked it up and there are
89 pubmed central articles referencing
this paper
and using this these cell lines
and these are we will provide these free
to anyone who asks for them so these are
free to you
to use in your laboratory if you want to
study the details
of a breast cancer line that you can
study with immunology
and really drill down on
specific questions about metastasis
since these are
divergent with respect to metastasis
so a similar line a newer line that we
published more recently this was
published back
in january of last year is an irb
mammary cancer model this uses the
so-called ndl
transgenic mouse which has a exon
deletion
programmed into it so it looks very much
like uh
one of the common human isoforms of her2
expression which is known as the delta
16 isoform
and this one uniquely again
transplantable into syngeneic mice
but this tumor cell line expresses
pdl1 in the tumor cells and so
pdl1 is uncommonly found in breast
cancer
but is sometimes found in breast cancer
and when it is
you'd have the opportunity to ask
what is the response to pdl1 therapy and
then
furthermore how can we improve that
therapy again this cell line is freely
available
to investigators that want to use it and
even though we just published it back in
january
there are already 14 publications in the
literature using this cell line
and i invite you to inquire with me
later if you're interested in
obtaining this cell line again we're
happy to share it
so in collaboration with kathy ferrara's
lab here at uc
davis and she's now moved to stanford we
asked where
and and she's an expert in high
intensity
focused ultrasound as a tumor ablative
therapy
we asked whether thermal ablation using
high intensity focused ultrasound would
release antigens
and increase the efficacy of antigen
presentation
and therefore the immune response to
to the tumor and we did this with and
without
anti-pd1 therapy you can see we use this
timeline
in the middle where we transplanted the
cells three weeks later
we performed a simultaneous
administration
into the tumor of cpg which is the
toll agonist
it's cng dna
recognized by toll receptor and
providing activation
itself along with anti-pd1 therapy
and along with ablation and
interestingly enough
to our surprise we found that you did
get a response
and so these are the green and red
curves that you see at the right
and you got that response both in the
tumor that you treated as well as the
tumor transplanted on the opposite side
of the animal
that tumor on the opposite side
is our way of measuring what's called
the abscopal response
but it can also be thought of as an
experimental version of a metastasis
and of course in patients it's not so
much the local cancer that
we have a problem treating but the
metastases
and so immunotherapy to be effective
should be effective not just against the
local therapy where we
inject and ablate inject the
cpg oligodeoxynucleotides
it should also be effective at the
contralateral site
so you can see we were a little
disappointed that we saw
in some ways better contralateral
response without
the ablation and we wondered about this
but what
um undaunted we went on and
asked whether we could
improve this with a different schedule
and so here
instead of doing everything at the same
time if you look at the timeline
you can see that we started with the
transplant we did
cpg injection along with anti-pd1
therapy
for another week and then came in with
the ablation and in this context
the combined ablation in the
contralateral site
gave us almost complete eradication of
both sites but
now complete eradication of that
second and even third location
of experimental metastasis and so what
we learned from this
is that you really need to prime the
immune system to be ready to recognize
new antigens
and then come in with antigen release
for those
antigens to be presented at which point
you get very good immune
tumor ablation of
metastatic sites so this has been
published and i invite you to
look at the details in the publications
that are listed here
this is kathy ferrara's group just
before
she moved to stanford so what about
humans can we do the same thing in human
context and so here my collaborators
at ucsf michael campbell and lawyer
laura esserman
asked whether we could in the context of
the i spy trial and for those of you who
don't know about the eye spy trial this
is an adaptive
therapy trial which has as a surrogate
endpoint
the efficacy seen with respect to
partial or
complete pathologic response in a
neoadjuvant setting
so rather than having to wait for five
or in breast cancer patients even 10
years to know whether
you had an effective therapy
we can get a readout immediately at the
time of surgery after the neoadjuvant
window
and patients it turns out who have
complete pathologic response at the time
of surgery
have a very good long-term prognosis so
those two things
correlate very well and so having that
very rapid ability to evaluate new
therapies
gave us the ability to begin to study
this and so we
have been looking at this in the eye spy
trial where
uh adding pebble blue zuma to
conventional paclitaxel um
along with the doxy rubison
cyclophosphamide
in a neoadjuvant setting is giving us
some
ideas about how to
add immunotherapy to our current breast
cancer
and because we have biopsies you can see
at the bottom the red
arrows depict biopsies we have both
before
of course for diagnosis but also on
therapy we can see
the effect on the immune system in the
context of this neoadjuvant
immunotherapy so in order to study that
we've developed some new tools we've
used
the acoya vectra multi-spectral imaging
analysis system
in order to try and do a better job of
characterizing the immune response both
before
during and after immunotherapy and so
this slide shows you
some of the panels we've developed you
can see we want to know where the pdl1
and pd1 are expressed but we also want
to know where
cd8 positive t cells all t cells
and macrophages are we want to know
where the fox p3 cells
are and so forth and
the ae183 is a cytokeratin marker that
marks where the epithelial cells are of
the cancer so we can
assess the proximity or interaction of
the immune cells with the cancer cells
and those panels panel one and two
were the first that we started with but
we've expanded this to panels
three and four and five and i'll in a
second
tell you why we went to that
in breast cancer as i alluded to in my
introductory remarks we have a big
problem which
is that we've begun to diagnose more and
more breast cancer with the advent
of screening mammography starting in the
mid 1980s
and as we had better and better
penetrance of screening mammography we
saw more and more
localized cancers and more and more
ductal carcinoma in situ lesions
so these
we hoped at the time would lead to
a corresponding decrease in late stage
breast cancer so
if we catch the cancers early we should
see
a dramatic decrease in finding cancers
that
present at late stage patients with
metastatic disease at the time
of presentation and unfortunately we
haven't really seen that
the epidemiologists tell us that many of
the cancers
and dcis lesions that we are detecting
and successfully treating
if we had left them alone they would
have not caused a problem and so this is
sort of the over diagnosis part
the bad side of screening mammography
and people go to a lot of trouble to
figure out how many women do we have to
treat so that we
actually find one woman
that we um have a benefit for and
um i won't get into all those numbers
that would be another talk
but the answer is that you have to
screen a lot of women you have to over
treat a lot of women or
in order to properly treat uh even one
woman
and so um many of my colleagues say well
is you know especially in radiology we
found something you called it cancer in
the pathology lab
why is that over diagnosis
and the person then i always have to say
is who's to blame for over diagnosis
it's the pathologist so when we call
something
cancer you have to treat it as cancer
and the question is
are some of the things that we call
cancer
not really potentially lethal
and if we could do a better job of
stratifying those
and here i refer you back to slide two
with jerome gallon
if we can maybe identify those that the
immune system is already kind of taking
care of
we'd be able to reduce the impact of our
over diagnosis
um on um on patients
and the health care system
so in the setting of
a consortium established by the national
cancer institute
to really interrogate this question this
is the so-called
mcl consortium which stands for
molecular and cellular
characterization of screen detected
lesions
the pathologists in the group right away
set as a priority evaluation of the
immune system
in these screen detected lesions whether
they were
screen detected dcis lesions or screen
detected lesions
in other organ systems
we all have the same question which is
could we
predict outcome based on specific
patterns
of immune cell infiltration
so these again are the panels that we
decided to develop
the process is not trivial and maybe not
quite ready for clinical practice
yet it involves multiple steps it
involves scanning
the image and here just a tissue array
core is shown
and you can see that the scan image can
then go through what's called spectral
on mixing this allows us to reduce
autofluorescence and increase the signal
to noise for each of the channels in
this case
six different channels plus a dappy
channel for nuclei
we then go through two different machine
learning
based analyses one to do tissue
segmentation
to show the cancer cells versus the
surrounding stroma
the next one to segment individual cells
and then each individual cell can be
phenotyped
with respect to its expression for each
of the markers
those phenotypes can come back to scores
the scores can
go back to scoring in the two different
segmented regions the tumor region
versus the stroma region
and this becomes a very powerful but
very big set of data
this is another example going through
the same kind of segmentation
with a different type of tumor and
showing a very different kind of outcome
and in this very simplistic comparison
of these two areas
i can show you one little feature that
sort of makes sense to our thought
process here and so if we compare
the t regulatory cell density that's the
fox p3 marker
in the top core versus the bottom core
you can see that the fox p3 is much
higher in the bottom core and
correspondingly the cd8
t cells the
killer t cells are markedly reduced in
the bottom
compared to the top so fewer fox p3
cells
gives you more cd8 cells and
more reaction to the tumor compared to
the bottom tumor having more fox p3
cells
regulating that immune response down
regulating the cd8 immune response and
having a tumor which is
much less recognized by the immune
system
oops sorry skip the head there so
t regulatory cells of course are more
complicated they
they come in different flavors we now
know that there are t
regulatory cells that are educated in
the thymus there are also t
regulatory cells educated in the
periphery and in tumor cells
in the setting of cancer and tumor cells
we think these
peripheral educated t regulatory cells
are particularly
important and that's an area of active
research
in many laboratories including my own
coming back to the eye spy trial we
asked this question about
what kind of immune landscapes do we see
in breast cancer
and using the multi-spectral imaging
and just showing you the five markers
that were used
the the six panel uh uh six marker panel
that we're using
on five cases you can see five different
kinds of patterns
in pattern five those are an example of
a tumor that itself is expressing pdl1
you can see that the tumor cells are
very
marked with the red color pdl1 this is
something that we
know happens in a lot of lung cancers
but fewer breast cancers but definitely
we think when it happens in breast
cancer it's important
but you can see all of the different
kinds of patterns you might expect so
pattern one
almost no inflammation whatsoever
pattern
two inflammation but essentially no
inflammation kind of extending into the
tumor cell
areas themselves so it's sort of an
immune excluded pattern
and then pattern four at the bottom you
can see
where the tumor cells are there's also a
lot of
infiltration of various um cd3 positive
and cd8 positive t
cells as well as macrophages so an
inflamed phenotype
so all those uh we we're now asking
actively which of those respond to
neoadjuvant pembrolozumab
and if we look also at
proximity of tumor cells to t cells we
can begin
to unravel which of the cells are
important
which of the cells are predictive and
how do these
impact this pd-1 pdl1
checkpoint with respect to outcomes
uh just a summary of those responses
where you see a higher
response you see
better p-values are the larger circles
a higher in the non-uh
complete response is blue so that's bad
higher in pathology pathologic complete
response
is red so wherever you see the large red
circle
that's predictive of a response to the
pembroluzumab
this differs based on whether you are
hurt too negative hurt to
um negative but hormone receptor
positive
or or negative for
all three markers triple negative at the
bottom but there are similarities across
all breast cancer types
these are just the controls so pd1
pdl1 is one of the checkpoints but as
many of you are aware there's a whole
host of
immune synapse checkpoints that might be
at
play mhc1 expression has been in the
literature recently
but everywhere on this chart that you
see
red letters those are drugs that are in
the pipeline
and in development for
possible immunotherapy for cancer and
this led us to think
back to them that match trial so in the
match trial
we said if every cancer has to have a
mutation
some of those mutations may be druggable
we ask can we do an
immunologic version of that so if every
cancer has to evade the immune system
are there checkpoints or immune synapses
that we can target for every cancer and
so we made a short list
of uh from that previous slide of
markers that we ought to look for
we've been looking at these markers
probably each of these markers deserves
its own
symposium with multiple talks but i
won't go into that i'll just point out
that
we can mark for each of these markers
here's
a dual mark with t cells along with the
aux 40 marker
here's the lag three marker
here's jitter um again
mark's importance cell subsets here's
vista or v7h5 along with
cd3
uh here's uh vista by itself without the
cd3 cell so you can see that there's
actually a range of expression from low
expressors to high expressors of vista
here's pepin h4 much less common but
definitely
scattered cells which are b7 h4 positive
here
here's b7h3 expressed
we think more on antigen presenting and
dendritic cells
interestingly here's tim3 tim3 you kind
of have to dial up the signal to see the
brightest cells
and we think it's probably the brightest
cells that are the most important
so all of these immune synapse pathways
are
part of the future i think of
immunotherapy and biomarkers for
immunotherapy
all right so lastly i want to tackle
sort of this pre-cancer problem in
breast cancer um the pre-cancer
problem i broke down into four
categories
the over diagnosis pro
problem i showed you is largely due to
over diagnosis of ductal carcinoma in
situ
and so we really need to do a better job
of telling which duct carcinoma in situ
is and is not going to progress i also
think that
some of the highest risk invasive
cancers really don't even
have that detectable intraductal
component
dcis is a heterogeneous array of
diseases but they all have this
increased risk of invasive cancer and
my colleague laura esserman will tell
you that
the the evidence does not support our
current standard of
care our current standard of care is
surgical therapy often followed by
radiation therapy
to completely eradicate the part of the
ductal tree that harbors this
intraductal neoplasm
and i really like this picture this is a
picture of
dcis kind of at its worst it's in action
you can see that it's not a simple
question
to know how the micro invasion
here at the bottom left at sort of
between
seven and nine o'clock is occurring you
can see that there's
necrosis in the center of this dcis and
you can see inflammatory cells scattered
around the periphery what are those
inflammatory
cells doing are they now permitting or
are they
suppressing the invasion of dcif
and so more and more we're looking at
the immune system
as a way to predict risk and response
and if we
begin to look at the inflammatory
response around dcis
you can see that we definitively have
different patterns in different dcis
cases
so the cases are listed at the top
conventional markers like her2
positivity and er positivity
are given at the uh at the top bars
there with
her2 being that bright blue her2
negative being light blue you can see
her2 expression is very common
we're going to come back to that very
common in dcis much more common
in dcis than it is in invasive cancer er
positivity very common also in dcis but
if we look at these
now her2 positive over at the left edge
and we look at the inflammatory response
these have some of the highest levels
of cd8 infiltration
but even these are broken down into
subgroups
of three or four cases each which have
um stromal pdl1
cd868 cells that express pdl1 at the far
left
versus macrophages for cd68 that
don't express pdl1 in that box
um two steps to the right and then
in the in between them high cd8 cells
but very few macrophages
there are also this group at the far
right that have very little inflammation
almost no t cells and no macrophages
infiltrating in or around in the stroma
the dcis cases at the far far
right there in the middle here's
another group that's somewhat
interesting with very little immune
response
but the dcis cells themselves express
pdl1
and so um at the right
no inflammation but it's not we don't
think because of pdl1
but in the middle here's a subgroup that
seems to have
pdl1 expression mitigating the immune
response to the dcis
right next to that here's cd68 cells
this time the macrophages are the ones
expressing the pdo one
so all these different categories are
important
we think proximity of t regs to other t
cells
is also important and we're working on
that so
very quickly these proximity analyses
can be added
you know what i just showed you was just
the very top of this picture the very
top of this heat map
but the heat map can be grown out to do
all this proximity analysis and
interrogation of which different
categories
we have for dcis lesions
lastly i want to introduce you to a
couple of concepts with regard to
pre-cancer the pre-cancer
atlas project is funded by
the moonshot initiative at the nci
here we're looking across different
tumor
types and asking whether we can
characterize those pre-cancers with
respect to risk
some of the sub-aims of the pre-cancer
project
involve the pre-cancer tumor immune
micro
environment 4.2 that i was just talking
about
as well as um just trying to get
an archive of the histology and
phenotypes
that we interrogate in this
cohort and so just some of the very
preliminary data
you might ask about ductal carcinoma in
situ and the clonal evolution of lesions
across space
and we've been studying that in addition
to gene expression analysis so
just like um we can interrogate the
immune cells in the histology we can
also
interrogate the immune cells as
as evidenced by the gene expression from
the bulk um rna expression from an
area of tumor
so lastly um how do we study this back
in experimental model systems so my lab
has worked with
the so-called minnow model that we
developed
which stands for mammary intraepithelial
neoplasia
outgrowth again these are transplant
model systems
of complex tissues in an immune intact
animal
and we found that you could have a
progression
consistently from pre-cancer to invasive
cancer in this model system
some of these are metastatic and some
are not they segregate
and it gives you a unique opportunity to
study
those pre-cancerous lesions that are the
most important
versus those that are the most innocuous
in another model system
the stat one knockout mouse which was
made
as a way to reduce natural killer t
cell function there's a nice um
cell article from the shriver lab that
points out that
these stat one knockout mice are
susceptible to
obligate intracellular pathogens like
listeria challenge
but it turned out these mice also
develop
mammary tumors and they developed a
unique pattern of mammary tumor that
we think is very analogous to
age-related
er positive breast cancer which is
the most common type of breast cancer
and also
despite an overall good prognosis in the
category still
the number one cause of breast cancer
death and we asked whether
this was because of the natural killer
t-cell defect associated with a
difference in inflammation
whereby you might hypothesize that
women as they age have reduced
ability to be effective at
immunosurveillance or immunosuppression
of
these age-related er positive breast
cancers and i invite you to look at this
paper in detail
very interestingly it showed that the
tumor cells
express chemo attractants for
macrophages but
also express chemo
repellents for macrophages and this
resulted in
macrophages that come close to the
cancer but then
are not able to attack the cancer or
prevent its spread
because of the chemo repellent effects
and those segregate into extracellular
vesicle fractions
and soluble fractions which are these
dot plots
that are very small down at the bottom
in panels gh and i
but i invite you to look at the camp at
the at the paper for more details
[Music]
so a few clues about how
dcis might progressing progress come
from her too
i think her2 expression it turns out
in dcis is seen
in at least 35 percent in this case
compared to invasive carcinoma at only
12 percent
so that i think provides a clue that
her2 might be recognized by the immune
system and might be
one of the ways that
the immune system prevents dcis at least
hurt to expressing dcis from invading
and so we asked a simple question
about how
might a dcis evade the immune system and
we think the answer is
at least partially related to
mis-expression of
isoforms of her2 and there are different
isoforms this is sort of less
well-known but is known in the
literature
that this pattern up at the very top
where you show that there's only
detection by the green antibody the
intracellular domain of her2
but there's complete loss of the
extracellular domain of her2
and we hypothesized that loss of the
extracellular domain of her2
while it still gives you her2 signaling
and oncogenic potential
reduces the ability of the immune system
to recognize
that her2 and additional patterns we're
seeing you do see some full length
um apparent full length but you also see
partial losses that can be subclonal
and you can see gradients of of loss of
the extracellular domain of her2 in that
pattern 4
at the bottom and that we
hypothesize may be due to
post-translational
cleavage events in her2 that are very
common
so going back to the mouse my colleague
josh schneider at duke was able to model
this in what's called the cranbow mouse
and this is unpublished data but we hope
it'll be published soon and you'll be
able to
reference the full paper but we were
able to engineer this mouse to express
the different isoforms
in the same mouse and then ask about the
outcomes of those mice
and very interestingly the p95 loss of
extracellular domain
does show a very different kind of
immune pattern
immune reaction and shows much more
invasiveness
if you do single cell rna sequence
analysis of those epithelial cells
and fibroblasts you can see that there's
a much greater impact of the
immune system and the fibroblast in
those
extracellular domain laws and even at
the very
earliest stages these p95
lesions are the most invasive and
show the least containment by the
stroma and the immune system so overall
this gives us some clues and i'm just
going to wrap up
here because i'm getting near the end of
my time that we may be able to
reclassify
dcis in part based on the immune
recognition of dcis
we may furthermore be able to treat dcis
with an immunotherapy that would
encourage the immune system to continue
or increase the immunosurveillance to
prevent that
emergence of an invasive lesion at the
stage of dcis
and that's sort of the goal
i hope that we get there i think you're
going to see these tools
that we're using in research implemented
in the clinic
in very short order in part maybe to
just begin to interrogate
response or prediction of response to
specific immunotherapies
and drugging the immune synapse but also
maybe
to reclassify and re-diagnose change our
classification schemes for invasive
cancers as well as in situ lesions into
those
that are immune evasive versus
immune non-invasive and kept in check
already by the immune system and and
this
i think will be an important part of the
future of pathology diagnostic
um i hope that i've convinced you that
teamwork is important here i talked
about many of my collaborators
all of them with unique skills and
subsets of expertise
we may all be blind men but we're all um
we're blind men and women but we're
also very good at working together and
communicating and so at the end of the
day hopefully we can get
a better picture of the elephant
the pathologist has to be involved in
many of the steps
along the way and i hope i've convinced
you of that that
it's one of the rules of pathologists to
put the
big picture together with the gene
expression the
cytokines and immunology the flow
cytometry
and put that in the context of what's
going on
where the rubber meets the road at the
point where the immune cells are
interacting
at the the invasive front of the tumor
and and how effective or non-effective
are those
so in summary the major problems
in cancer including better treatment of
aggressive and metastatic disease
reducing
over diagnosis and overtreatment disease
and finding
real pre-cancers very early these
nascent lethal pre-cancers
that are defined at least in part by
a very early evidence of immune escape
as well as immune
stromal interaction are
possible using some of these new
technologies
for research and translation i showed
you a lot of multiplex
immunohistochemistry sort of a blend of
flow cytometry
and conventional histology i showed you
some single cell
rna sequence data and that's becoming
more and more important
important in research and giving us more
targets to
handle these but as you saw this becomes
a very big picture big data problem
which requires new
computing and informatics tools to
handle both of those
and it takes a team of the blind
scientists and a chance to put them
together to make meaningful progress so
with that
i'll acknowledge all of my collaborators
and co-investigators
as well as the funders and the industry
partners that have made
all this possible and i'm happy to take
any questions